لذلك قالت هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه قولها ان القوات
الروسيه شنت هجوما جويا واسعا خلال الساعه
الماضيه على البلاد مستهدفه العاصمه
في شرقي البلاد وغربها وقالت الهيئه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تتصدت للهجوم الذي
استخدمت فيه خمس وثلاثون مسيره ايرانيه
الصنع من نوع شاهد مشيره الى ان الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت 32 مسيره كانت
معظمها يحاول استهداف العاصمه كياف
عدنان عن اخر التطورات والبيانات
الاوكرانيه المتعلقه بتطورات الوضع في في
الفيف التي تعود للمشهد من جديد
نعم هي ليله طويله على معظم المدن
الاوكرانيه ازدهار عندما نتحدث عن موجه
هجوم كبيره تضمنت 35 مسيره من نوع الشاهد
بحسب القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه فان اثنين
واثنتين من هذه المسيرات اسخطت لكن ثلاث
مسيرات تمكنت من وصول الاهداف يتم الحديث
بشكل اساسي عن الحديث عن كييف شمال كييف
هناك ايضا كانت هناك ضربه بشكل اساسي هذه
المسيرات بحسب اعلان القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه طالت كانت تحاول استهداف كياب
بشكل اساسي عشرين من هذه المسيرات نتحدث
كانت تحاول الوصول الى كيف لكن اسقطت كلها
بحسب القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه باستثناء
مسيره واحده اصابت هدفا في الشمال لكن لم
يتم الاعلان الحديث عن ان الاهداف كانت
تريد الوصول الى مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه
وايضا منشات حيويه بشكل اساسي وهو ما تم
الاعلان ايضا عنه في حيث المسيره اصابت من
حيويه هامه لكن دون مزيد من التوضيحات
بشان هذا الموضوع على ايه حال هي موجه
جديده من هجمات المسيرات تطال المدن
الاوكرانيه ليله طويله كانت عندما نتحدث
عن منذ وقت طويل لم نستمع عن ضربه تستهدف
بهذا التوقيت لكن اذا اردنا الحديث عن كيف
فالاسبوع الماضي كنا امام ضربه كانت توصف
بانها الاقوى منذ اسابيع عندما تم
استهدافها باثنين عشر صاروخا باليستيا
وايضا بالاضافه الى مسيرات على ايه حال
هذا الموضوع هذه الاستهدافات هي منصه
تستخدمها للمطالبه بمزيد من الدعم العسكري
وخصوصا بحسب ما اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني اليوم ديمتري كوليبا الذي تحدث
عن ان الفريق العسكري والفريق الدبلوماسي
الاوكراني الخاص بالرئيس الاوكراني يعمل
بشكل اساسي على الضغط للحصول على مزيد من
الذخيره هناك حاجه ملحه للذخيره بالاضافه
الى العربات المدرعه هذه الحاجه تعود ايضا
الى الاوضاع الصعبه في جبهات الشرق بحسب
ما اعلنت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
التي قالت بان تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه
يرافقه جلب مزيد من الاحتياطات من القوات
الروسيه والتفوق عددي كبير من القوات
الروسيه وان الاوضاع صعبه جدا وهو ما
يستلزم احضار مزيد من الدفاعات او المعدات
للقوات الاوكرانيه بشكل اساسي